[Music]
how about an amazing fact in 1995
Maryann Franco was in a serious car
accident that injured her spine and
consequently caused her to go blind in
both eyes Maryann spent the next 21
years in Okeechobee Florida walking with
a cane and struggling to live in a world
of darkness that was until Franco fell
in her home hitting her head and
injuring her neck the doctor said she'd
need to have an operation performed on
her spine to relieve the pain now neck
injuries usually aren't part of a
success story but when Maryann awoke in
the hospital recovery room she tried to
get the nurse's attention saying lady
you with all that purple on give me
something for pain her amazed niece
sitting nearby asked what did you say
meri the statement was especially
surprising because prior to her 1995
accident Franco was also color blind the
operation seems to have restored not
only her vision but now for the first
time in her life she also has the
ability to see color her amazed doctor
neurosurgeon John Afshar is calling the
recovery of her sight a miracle 70 year
old Mary Franco has no question it's a
gift from God I really believe she said
with all my heart
he gave me back my sight now that she
has her vision back she's very excited
to see her friends pets and especially
seven grandchildren she's never looked
at her chores have become easier and she
deeply appreciates the simple things we
all take for granted with her eyes
welling with tears Maryann says the Sun
is coming through the trees oh god it is
so wonderful to see you know the Bible
tells us that healing the blind was one
of Jesus favorite miracles stay with his
friends were going to learn more as
amazing facts brings you this edition of
Bible answers lie
welcome to Bible answers live with
author and evangelist pastor Doug
Batchelor is understanding God's Word a
challenge
are they passages of scripture that are
a mystery to you maybe it's difficult to
reconcile what you've read in the Bible
too what you boys believe if you have
Bible related questions stay tuned to
get honest practical answers straight
from the Word of God on Bible answers
live Bible answers live is the
production of amazing facts ministries
dedicated to spreading the gospel of
Jesus Christ to the entire world our
lines are open so call us now at
[Music]
806-853-9949 interactive Bible study and
you can call in with your Bible
questions right now is a good time to do
that we've got our phone lines wide open
if you have a Bible question pick up the
phone it is a free phone call here's the
number 800 god says eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven and if
you call now excellent chance you'll get
your question on tonight's program one
more time 800 God says that's eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven and I'm Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross good evening frames and
passage let's begin the program with
prayer dear father in heaven we thank
you that we have this opportunity once
again to study your word and we always
want to ask the Holy Spirit to come and
guide our hearts and our minds as we
open up the pages of the Bible we ask a
blessing on those who are listening Lord
and just lead us all into a clearer and
a full understanding of your word for we
ask this in Jesus name Amen amen
I'll pass that idea open the program by
talking about a fairly remarkable
occurrence a miracle that happened to
this lady who was blind banged her head
which you know in itself would be as
most situations a a bad thing not a good
thing but it turned out to really be the
the catalyst to restore her sight and
what an experience that must be I'm when
you think of the census you think of
smell and taste and touch and sight and
hearing
if somebody woulda give one out probably
the last one that you would want to give
up is your site it just means so much to
us and here to have your site taken away
and then miraculously restored what an
experience that must be especially after
20 almost 21 years and you know that the
one theory the doctor says you care I
believe it was a miracle because
whenever God does something like that
you know if if the blood was cut off to
a certain part of the brain or the eyes
you know that would atrophy after 20
years and and it would be permanent and
that's why the doctors are dumbfounded
he said perhaps the next surgery
increased flow to a blood flow to a part
of the brain or you know they're
mystified but she looks upon it it's
just a wonderful miracle and then there
is no explanation why for the first time
in her life because she had the accident
when she was 50 she had been color blind
her entire life and now she can see
colors and it's an amazing news clip you
know people can go online and see it but
it makes me think about people question
when Jesus worked these miracles of
opening people's eyes in restoring their
sight and there's several cases there
was blind bartimaeus there was the case
of the blind man in the Gospel of John
chapter 9 and matter of fact you can
read Matthew 21:14 then the blind in the
lame came to him in the temple and He
healed them so as multiple times Jesus
opened the eyes of the blind in Luke
4:18 he said he has sent me to heal the
brokenhearted to proclaim Liberty to the
captives and recovering of sight to the
blind
now sometimes blindness in the Bible and
Jesus healing the blind was synonymous
with his opening the spiritual sight of
people who were spiritually blind of
course Christ talking about the
religious leaders said you blind guides
that are leading the blind and we've
heard the expression if the blind lead
the blind they'll fall in the ditch and
there Jesus is talking about spiritual
blindness and he makes an interesting
statement in John 9 39 Christ said for
judgment I have come into the world that
those who do not see may see
and those who see maybe made blind and
what Jesus meant by that is his teaching
helped some of the poor and the
uneducated like the Apostles to have
great spiritual insight and the
religious leaders their hearts were
hardened in spiritual blindness and
there are a lot of people out in the
world right now that are blind
spiritually and the only way to have our
eyes opened and really have vision
knowing what the purpose of life is is
through Christ in His Spirit he still
works miracles and opens behind the eyes
of the blind physically as well as
spiritually and we've got a book that
talks about people that are plugging
their ears and their eyes are blinded
deliberately they're blind to the things
of God and we want to make sure we don't
fall in that category we have a book and
the book is called hidden eyes and
closed ears and we'll be happy to send
this anybody wanting to learn how they
can make sure that they have spiritual
sight we don't want to be closing our
eyes spiritually from the truths of
God's Word again the book is called
hidden eyes and closed ears will be
happy to send this to anybody who calls
and asks the phone line for our free a
resource this evening is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
again that number is 885 67 47 and as
for the book called hidden eyes and
closed ears and if you have a Bible
question our phone line here to the
studio is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven that's 800 God says
for 63 72 97 if you have a Bible
question it's a good time friends to
pick up your phone give us a call we
have a number of lines that are still
open so give us a call and we'd love to
hear from you this evening well we're
gonna go to our first caller we have
aired listening from Greenville North
New York Edie welcome to the program
are we there yeah you're on very good
appreciate your study Bible it's really
been an eye-opener using the center
column references for Samuel 16 14 verse
Samuel a question I have is a dispensing
spirit from the Lord trouble so it says
first that the Spirit of the Lord
departed from the soul and a distressing
Spirit the Lord troubled him explain
that well it it
doesn't mean that God has evil spirits
that he sends but in the same way that
the devil sort of needed permission to
tempt Jobe when when God withdrew the
good spirit now if someone has the light
of the Lord in their life
if the light is rejected automatically
darkness comes in Saul when he was first
anointed king he was filled with the
spirit he had angels and the Spirit of
God guiding him but through persistent
rebellion and pride he eventually drove
away the light of the Lord and the evil
spirits came in and you know David later
it talks about David would come and sing
and play music and you know David Psalms
were full of spiritual meaning and it
says he would be refreshed and the
darkness would go away so there's no
vacuum really then yeah all of us you
know Jesus said if you're not with me
you're against me it's is one of the
other the Bible is pretty clear yeah
well you know the way it's worded a
distressing spirit from the Lord you
think why would God send an evil spirit
but it's really that God just in
withdrawing his spirit the evil spirits
came in you know I think our free offer
hidden eyes and closed ears kind of
deals a little bit with that how that
you know if we turn away from God and
we're really opening ourselves up to the
devil coming in guiding or influencing
an individual so I think it kind of goes
along with that free offer again if
you'd like to receive that air or
anybody listening just give us a call on
our resource line and the number is 883
five six seven four seven that's 883
five six seven four seven with your or
ask for the free offer called hidden
eyes and closed ears and our phone line
here to the studio with your Bible
question 800 463 seventy to ninety seven
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven we have Edward listening from
Highland California Edward walk with the
program hi how are you doing well thanks
for calling in okay I've got a question
ready okay you know John 3:16 a very
popular Bible verse and a lot of people
note by heart I was looking at my Bible
the other day the wording is a little
bit different than what most people go
by yeah well what's your say
I says for God so loved the world he
gave His only Son so that everyone who
believes in Him might not perish but
might have eternal life
most the time I hear that this shall not
perish shall have eternal life it seems
like it's not so certain what yeah what
version you reading new American Bible
doesn't say new American Standard okay
you know that some of the translations
try to simplify and modernize the
language I personally think that
sometimes when they do that that some of
the beauty is lost and even at times the
the actual meaning has changed but well
go ahead I think it's the ones that the
Catholic Church uses yeah well I'm sure
there's a lot of good things in there
but you know most of us know we've
memorized
John 3:16 from the King James you know
for God so loved the world he gave His
only begotten Son that whosoever
believeth in him shall not perish but
have everlasting life
sounds more definitive doesn't it well
you know the King James Bible is a
masterpiece the there is no no language
in the world are no book in the world
has had more influence on the English
language than the King James Version it
if it was like the textbook of English
for several hundred years well you know
there the King James Bible actually is
drawn a lot from one of the first
English translations which would be you
know Wickliffe and then Tyndale some of
the early English reformers translated
the Bible and the King James is the
masterpiece because they had so many
scholars working on it
that I've got great respect for it now
the new King James Version is very much
like the King James they've just
modernized some of the words that we use
you know we don't say thee and thou and
so yeah it's a tremendous translation we
actually have a book we can send you a
free copy that talks about the Word of
God and some of the differences would
you like to copy that Edward well a good
Bible and I like this what you're saying
about the King James Bible it just seems
to me that it was written so much after
the original text that maybe the King
James Bible meaning what do you think I
don't think so I think that matter of
fact I think the new American Bible
you're using is has been rewritten more
recently
sumit let me give you something to think
about some of the the translators of the
King James Bible actually had access to
manuscripts that we don't have today
during world war one and two and even
some of the wars in Europe great
libraries were burned they didn't have
things on microfilm they didn't have
things digitized and a lot of scholarly
information that was used by some of the
great reformers has been lost but they
they had more probably manuscripts of
the New Testament than we have today so
you know we've got copies of copies
today I would think this like the
Catholic Church of the Vatican would
have really good copy
well the Catholic Church does have a
main Bible called the Vaticanus you know
there's three primary manuscripts for
the New Testament now the Old Testament
the Jews have got many many records of
that nobody ever argues the Old
Testament because the the Jewish people
have a black belt they sort of have a
copyright on that but the the three
manuscript see are the signee Atticus it
was a manuscript fountain in st.
catherine's monastery on mount sinai
Nevada keenest a manuscript found in the
Vatican Library and then Texas receptive
but yeah just kind of with reference the
Old Testament we can go back to the Dead
Sea Scrolls which were actually dated
and actually buried there in a cave
prior to the time of Christ and it has
all of the Old Testament books except I
think all portions of it except for the
book of Esther or Ruth I forget four
parts of every book except for Esther
Esther and so you can go back and you
can verify the old testament say yep
absolutely what we have in our Bibles is
indeed accurate and then the New
Testament there's a number of Greek
manuscripts that has been scattered all
over the place and people have gathered
these manuscripts together and put them
together in a New Testament Greek and
this several Textus Receptus is probably
one of the most well-known of these
collection of Greek manuscripts well
yeah you have the Catholics include some
Old Testament books like in the
Apocrypha the Maccabees that what I when
I said I don't think they argue about it
they're pretty agreed on the translation
of it when you're talking about you know
Genesis Exodus through Malachi that it's
not a that's a different question on
there are some books that the Catholic
Church felt were inspired that most
Protestants thought were maybe
historical books but they didn't fall
within the Canon of inspiration well he
probably used the the Torah very much
like us just to answer your question
Jesus quoted 10% of everything jesus
said he quotes from the Old Testament
Jesus never quotes from the Maccabees
Jesus quotes from Deuteronomy all three
times he was tempted in the wilderness
Jesus quotes from Jeremiah Jesus quotes
from Ezekiel Jesus quotes from Daniel he
quotes extensively from Moses because he
refers to Moses writings many times and
I'll give you an example if you look in
Luke 24 it says after the resurrection
beginning at Moses and all the prophets
he expounded unto them in all the
Scriptures the things concerning
himself so Jesus was very well familiar
he gave long Bible studies going through
the Old Testament he went through the
law he went there Jesus quoted the
Psalms many times 10% of everything
Jesus said was a quote from the Old
Testament hey you know what Edward will
be happy to send you a book it's called
the ultimate resource that deals with
this subject and that will it's a free
gift just you call the number pastor
Ross is giving you and that will we get
that to you yeah the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you can ask to the book
called the ultimate resource it's all
about the Bible tell you a little bit
about the various translations and the
manuscripts I think you'll find that
helpful again the number is 883 five six
seven four seven that is the resource
line and if you have a Bible question
the number to call is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven again 800 460 372
97 with your Bible question we have
Brian who is listening from New York
Brian welcome to the program thanks get
real close to your phone are you hearing
me now a little better thanks and your
question my question my question is I've
been doing some independent research
regarding the whole system of salvation
and one of the main doctrine that has
been talking of the denomination is that
there is a regulatory system in place in
respect to the law however in other
mainstream teaching it is taught that
the law was abolished because Greece is
no the what would person say the in
thing so to speak so my question is if
that system was abolished
what didn't play well when it talks
about the law that's very important to
understand the word the law in the Bible
it's used many different ways sometimes
when it says the law of speaking of the
Old Testament Scriptures the Torah and
it's including all the writings in the
Old Testament sometimes the law might be
referred to the ceremonial laws and the
ordinances and sometimes the law is
referring to the moral code or the
Commandments and you of course you have
to read the context so when the Bible
says we're not under the law but under
grace and pastor ross there's a few
places though that that appears that
doesn't mean we're not under an
obligation to obey the law because the
Bible's pretty clear not everyone that
says Lord Lord will enter the kingdom
but they that do the will of my father
and the law of God is called the will of
God and so if a person is you know
committing adultery and they say I'm not
after the law I'm under grace well
they're kidding themselves they still
need to keep that day law you know the
verse you're referring to is Romans
chapter 6 verse 14 and 15 paul writes
for sin shall not have dominion over you
for you're not under the law but under
grace and then he says what then shall
we sin because we are not under the law
but under grace
certainly not that's Romans chapter 6 14
and 15 yes so Paul is telling us Brian
that when we come to Jesus were no
longer under the penalty of the law it
doesn't mean that we're not under an
obligation to obey because over and over
it says if you love me keep my
Commandments blessed are those who do
His commandments and I've kept my
father's Commandments Paul even says I
think it's Romans 2:13 not the hearers
of the law will be just before God but
the doers of the law will be justified
so when Paul talks about being under
grace he means we're not under the
penalty of the law when we accept Christ
and we surrender and follow him it
doesn't mean we're free to break the
moral law we don't have to keep the laws
regarding the ceremonial system they are
nailed to the cross it's not necessary
for us to sacrifice lambs Paul's pretty
clear circumcision means nothing matter
fact Paul says circumcision is nothing
and uncircumcision is nothing keeping
the commandments is what is important so
that was actually a modern translation
so we have a lesson that talks
specifically about the relationship
between law and grace would you like
that book Brian certainly yeah it's go
ahead I'm not sure which one you
thinking of but there's a book I'm
looking at it says discuss God's grace
blot out the law that's what I was
thinking I think that'll explain the
subject
great detail just give us a call on a
resource line Brian the number again is
883 five six seven four seven you can
ask for the book does God's grace blot
out the law and any anyone framed if
you'd like to learn more about the
subject give us a call and we'll be
happy to send this book to you a next
holy is Justin listening in California
Justin welcome to the program
hello um I was just wondering if there's
anything that God cannot forget a good
question
you know the bible does talk about that
blasphemy against the Holy Spirit jesus
said he says this in Matthew I think
also in mark and pastor Ross might find
a couple of those references all manner
of sin and blasphemy will be forgiven
the sons of men but blasphemy against
the Holy Spirit will not be forgiven in
this life or in the life to come
and people when they try and figure out
what is the unpardonable sin they
imagine to themselves all the you know
worse things they can think of they
think well ways it'd mean killing your
parents does it mean killing a child you
know all those things would be horrific
sins but there are people in the Bible
that did those things and they were
forgiven and so blasphemy against the
Holy Spirit is really an ongoing
rejection of the work of the Holy Spirit
in your life so that you're saying Holy
Spirit is not going to be God over me
but I'm gonna be God in my life and it's
blasphemy in the spirit it's a it's the
sin God cannot forgive because it's the
sin for which a person will not repent
you know the verses you're referring to
it's actually found in three of the
Gospels you got a Matthew Matthew
chapter 12 31 mark 4 verse 12 and then
also Luke chapter 6 37 where it says
Olsson will be forgiven except blasphemy
against the Holy Spirit now when you
think of the word blasphemy blasphemy is
putting yourself in the place of God
that's one of the definitions for that
so the work of the Holy Spirit is to
convict a person of sin but when we
choose to resist the Holy Spirit and
refused to follow the leading of the
Spirit through the word
we're hardening our hearts against the
Holy Spirit mm-hmm that's a dangerous
thing yeah and we have actually a book
that talks about that called beyond
mercy
what is the unpardonable sin and we'll
send you a free copy of that if you'd
like Justin you just call the research
all you need to do is call 808 three
five six seven four seven and you can
ask for the book called beyond mercy and
for you just know anybody wanting to
learn more about the subject just give
us a call and we'll be happy to send
that to you again the number is 883 five
six seven four seven that is the
resource line and the phone line here to
the studio with your Bible question this
evening is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven eight hundred four
63 72 97 we'll be happy to take your
call in the air well thank you for your
call Justin our next caller is ed and he
is listening from Chicago Illinois ed
welcome to the program oh I love your
show I love you guys well thank you for
calling thank you I was talking to a
friend of mine yesterday who is a
Christian she's always been a a
Christian religion that we are and she
was very frustrated she had three
question several questions but one of
them was what is the purpose of life and
this course I had my little Christian
answer you know like you give sword to
God Sarah but that didn't fly very well
and then she asked me we've got it Bob
why I mean what is he waiting to come
because as time goes by more people are
born or before that I'd be lost had he
come say in 1970 I would not be here and
say that I'm gonna go to hell then I
wouldn't have gone to hell so I don't
have an intelligent answer to give when
it has been asked this same thing
several times I'm wondering if you have
any answer for me and my answer applying
thank you very much all right ed thank
you very much that's a very good
question if if God is love you might
start up by saying why did he allow evil
why didn't did he make a devil and if
Jesus came to redeem us two thousand
years ago why is it taking him so long
to come back why does he tarry well one
reason the Bible tells us in second
Peter chapter three God is not willing
that any should perish but that all
should come to repentance so the longer
the Lord Waits it's two more people will
be born but some who are living
would not be ready and there's other
things that are going on the the you
know when when you're waiting to pick a
fruit timing is everything if you pick
it too soon
if it's unedible if you pick it too late
it's rotten there's a time when it's
exactly ripe and the whole battle
between good and evil that is revealed
here in this world and the love of God
revealed in Jesus coming to die for our
sins it's gonna reach a point where
things are perfectly ripe now exactly
when that is we don't know I think that
the coming of the Lord is very soon
because you know it's just interesting
that if you add up the ages in the Bible
it somewhere around 4000 BC we don't
know the exact date it's a creation you
just add up the ages and about 4000
years after that Christ was born and
then here we are now 2,000 yesterday
that's 6,000 years roughly from creation
and then we spend a thousand years
living and reigning with the Lord during
the Millennium it's like a thousand-year
Sabbath I think we're at the point right
now between those two epochs where the
Lord is gonna come you know pastor Beck
is interesting you you mentioned that in
2nd Peter chapter 3 verse 8 Peter writes
these words he says but beloved do not
forget this one thing that one day with
the Lord is as a thousand years and a
thousand years as one day and then verse
9 he says the Lord is not slack
concerning his promise as some men count
slackness but is long-suffering toward
us not willing that any should perish
but that all should come to repentance
it's talking about the second coming and
then it says but the day of the Lord
will come as a thief in the night so
there's the promise Jesus will come
although it might seem that there's this
time of tearing prior to the coming yeah
absolutely and you know we do have a DVD
that you guys think you can watch it
online for free called cosmic conflict
and it explains this battle between good
and evil where the devil came from why
the Lord is waiting until things are
ripe before he comes back and that's
what it says in Revelation he's coming
to harvest the earth when it is fully
ripened we think it's reaching that
point
very rapidly so you want to be ready
friends cosmic conflict is the name of
the video we can send you one from
amazing facts or you can watch it on
YouTube
don't go anywhere there are more Bible
questions coming in just a moment
[Music]
Bible answers live we return in just a
moment if you're looking for Bible based
materials for further study sign up for
amazing faxes free correspondence Bible
study course or check out our sale
catalog featuring hundreds of inspiring
books and tapes to order call our
resource line at eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that's
800 eight three five six seven four
seven amazing facts is a faith-based
listener-supported ministry operating
exclusively through the generosity of
your prayers and financial gifts we
would love to hear from you write to us
at peel Box 909 Roseville California
nine five six seven eight or online at
amazing facts org you're listening to
Bible answers live with Pastor Doug
Batchelor if you have a Bible related
question call us now to receive clear
honest answers directly from Scripture
we have a few lines open so please give
us a call the phone number to the studio
is 800 God says that's 800 463 seven to
nine seven
if you've enjoyed Bible answers life
you'll love Pastor Doug's book of Bible
answers straight from the broadcast the
very best questions and answers have
been compiled as an awesome resource for
Bible study and personal evangelism each
answer has been expanded with more Bible
verses and insightful commentary the
book of Bible answers can be yours today
for just $12 call now
we're back listening friends and yes we
are live if you have a Bible question we
invite you to give us a call that number
is 888-259-3826
mark of the beast' Antichrist
tribulation all of the hot topics
connected with the second coming in
Bible prophecy are in their Bible
prophecy truth com and I think in just a
moment here we're gonna go back to the
phone so it looks like some calls have
come in but one let folks know about our
free offer again for this evening those
of you who just joined us we do have a
book we'd be happy to send it to anybody
who gives us a call and asks our
resource number is 883 five six seven
four seven and the free offer this
evening is called hidden eyes and closed
ears it's an intriguing title but it's
talking about how we can see literally
or physically and yet be blind
spiritually what does the Bible have to
say about how we can have our eyes
anointed as Revelation chapter 3 says
with the Holy Spirit in order to
understand the word to understand truth
I'll be happy to send it to anybody who
calls and asks it's called hidden eyes
and closed ears and our resource phone
number if phone number is 883 five six
seven four seven it's free absolutely
our next call is Lucy listening from New
York Jamestown Lucy welcome to the
program we Christians
celebrate or give an offering for like
the Passover and there's two other ones
that some of the churches say that we
should do
I wondered because it was that Jewish
law that we shouldn't be keeping or was
it because the Last Supper was on the
Passover well the Last Supper up sorry
go ahead I'll let you finish your
question the Last Supper really is
replaces the Passover you know because
Christ you're right when yeah the last
separate was during the Passover but
then he said you know this is what you
do the bread represents my body the
grape juice represents my blood and if
you read in 1st Corinthians 5:7 Paul is
extremely clear he says for indeed
Christ is our Passover who was
sacrificed for us so we don't need to
sacrifice physical lambs and eat a
physical lamb for the Passover when we
partake of that bread and drink that
grape juice that's a symbol for the pure
it's unleavened bread the body sinless
life of Christ and that unfermented wine
or grape juice represents his blood that
gives us life the life is in the blood
and and that would be true with the
other Jewish feasts you know they were
all they had a spiritual significance
that we should still apply to our lives
but it's not necessary for us to travel
to Jerusalem and go to the temple and
offer sacrifice which was part of the
old law obviously we can't do that now
the temple is not even there and they
don't offer sacrifice or you know it's a
good idea but in our church we think
that you know a good time to do a
communion service is during the time of
spring Passover for the Jews and roughly
the time of Easter for the Christians
but because it is the time of year that
Jesus was sacrificed
that doesn't mean you only need to do
communion once a year many churches do
it quarterly future churches do
communion weekly but I think that's too
Quentin it gets to where it sort of
loses its certain significance but yeah
nothing wrong with doing an offering in
keeping with those feasts it obviously
doesn't need to be a lamb or a goat I
wouldn't do that I wouldn't have the
heart to kill a that's good hey you know
we have a book that talks a little bit
about this Lucy we'll send you a free
copy or anyone that wants to know more
it's called feast days and Sabbath's
feast days and Sabbath's and we'll be
happy to send you a free copy or you can
read it online the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven that is the resource line you
can ask for the book called feast days
and Sabbath's or you can read it at
amazing facts dot o-r-g our next call is
wallace listening from the Dells in
Oregon Wallace welcome to the program hi
I'd like to get right to my questions
hoping to make it brief I've listened to
several videos where you talk about the
second coming and usually a near the
start of those you'll mention the the
false messiah but in the course of the
teaching later on you you don't seem to
get back to that or elaborate on that
and I I feel like it makes me nervous
when I hear the church preaching that
there's going to be this great world
leader who's going to do this and that
and he could be waiting in the wings at
the present time I don't really know how
that doctrine is justified or not
justified but I don't feel that's
consistent with the nature of Satan to
share the spotlight with anyone and so I
feel that once the stage is set and
maybe the world in the church has
believed that there has been somebody or
is somebody on the scene who are they're
calling the Antichrist then out of the
clouds is going to appear the Messiah
and everybody's going to think it's the
Messiah and it's going to be Satan
pretending to be the Messiah and that's
why that's going to be
such a powerful deceit and delusion and
I just wondered what you would agree
with me about that and disagree with me
about that
well first we agree with Jesus I believe
that there is going to be masterpiece of
deception when the disciples asked about
Christ's return and the second coming
the first thing Jesus said is and this
is Matthew chapter 24 for take heed that
no one deceives you for many will come
in my name saying I am the Christ and
deceive many there have been many false
Christ's now what I mean by that is
people who claim to be Jesus and
everyone from you know Jim Jones and and
David Koresh and they've been several
others that have claimed to be Christ
through history and there's probably
mental asylums still filled with people
that say they're Jesus I met somebody
once on the street that was absolutely
serious and they said they were the
incarnation of Christ you know I think
they may have had a mental disorder but
that's that's not the final deception
because jesus said if you go to verse 11
many false prophets will arise and
deceive many and I think that Satan
himself is going to do a masterpiece of
deception and just like you said
appearing to be Christ whether he's
gonna come in the clouds I'm not so sure
because Jesus said if someone says
behold he's in the desert or in secret
chambers going out forth
I don't think Satan's gonna be able to
replicate Jesus coming in the clouds of
angels but he'd no doubt he'll use
supernatural power and Paul tells us I
think it's 2nd Corinthians 11 I believe
where he said Satan himself is
transformed into an angel of light and
so the devil is gonna come you know
appearing to be Christ and deceive now
so where would we disagree I don't know
that we do within what I've said the
part where where I'm saying that the
church is getting ready to receive
someone that they're gonna call the
Antichrist because he's this wonderful
world leader who's solving all these
problems and I I feel like in
because Satan is also a great
counterfeiter that this person that
everybody is pointing to could very well
be sort of Satan's John the Baptist and
just as John I see that's that's well
put I understand what you're saying oh
yeah that that's that's good Satan's
John the Baptist I know what you mean so
someone who's kind of like pointing the
way I think they're probably gonna be
many that will point to Satan and say oh
this is him and I don't think there's
any one world leader as some churches
say that is gonna be like half human
half devil you know this old Rosemary's
Baby concept that somehow the devil is
gonna have relations with a human and
there's gonna be this half devil half
person that's gonna rule the world and
the tribulation I don't believe that I
think Satan has got many people that are
deceived and talks in revelation about
three unclean spirits that go forth to
the rulers of the earth to the Beast the
dragon and the false prophet
so the kings of the earth committed
fornication with a woman and Babel in
revelation 17 so I think there's several
of these things that are happening at
one time now wondering what we could
send the wallis that would go along with
well we do have a study guide called who
is the Antichrist and that kind of ties
in I think with the question the number
to call is eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and wallis you
can ask for that study guy called who is
the Antichrist and for anyone listening
just give us a call ask for that
resource for a be happy to send it to
you you can also read it online at the
amazing facts website just amazing facts
dot o-r-g
next caller is Shana and she's listening
in weimar California Shana welcome to
the program will God's true people have
healing miracles and if so how can we
tell the difference
alright good question I do believe in
miracles I believe that there are
miracles of healing even today and
pastor Ross and I prayed for people
before that you know we're declared by
the doctors to
you know some kind of terminal illness
or cancer and and they just you know
we're we're healed so that there's no
evidence of it anymore and they're doing
fine to this day I you know we started
the program tonight talking about a lady
that had kind of a miraculous healing
from her blindness so but I think before
the Lord comes you're gonna see more and
more miraculous healing how do you know
a true healing from a false healing well
you know one way I'd say is the way that
it's done some of the Roadshow antics
that evangelist use for healing where
they say you know they kind of cover the
rise and say reach towards your
television set somebody out there you
got pain in your lower back God wants to
heal it I don't ever see Jesus doing
anything like that or any of the
apostles so there's some really strange
carnival kind of healings and Jesus said
you'll know them by their fruits if
someone says that they're healing with
the power of God but then their lives
are out of harmony whether the power of
God or the law of God there's something
dubious because the devil can make a
person sick and they just remove the
sickness and make it look like a healing
and then finally been healed they he's
just taken away his affliction so the
devil has a counterfeit for every truth
of God including healings but I do
believe there'll be real healings in the
last days as well okay do you have any
study guides on it or the only thing
I've noticed is I kind of try to study
but um and it's like the only thing I've
noticed was that with the Lord when
jesus healed or the disciples is that
they did a full healing it was like
complete I was just wondering though if
you guys had any city guys yeah well we
do have a study guide that talks about I
think it's called does God inspire
science and probably yeah talked about
true and false strategies and psychics
yeah it's called does God inspire
psychics and astrologers and I will be
happy to send anybody what's about any
of that
yeah true and false prophets in there
what are the criteria same thing for
those who do healing you know number two
coal is 883 five six seven four seven
that is the resource line and just give
us a call there and ask for that study
guide called
got inspire psychics and astrologers and
we'll be able to send it to anybody who
calls and asks thank you for your call
Shauna I Mexico Lee is either listening
from Ontario Canada Eva welcome to the
program hi yes good evening I love your
voice I love you guys I love you what
you're doing here blessing us abundantly
I really have to say that I listen your
every week and I just love it my
question is I have a situation and my
family I'm single mom I'm raising twin
girls they'd a blessing to me and I have
a son my son is the oldest he's 40 years
old and you have a son 15
his name is James I'm just going through
chemo now from me God is number one in
my life always was and always will be I
don't understand why is this happened to
me to us you say James is going through
some kind of Hingham he have a cancer
chemotherapy yes yes he's destroying
this little body the first time yes we
do everything we pray we I am very
faithful to God I don't understand wife
happen to us well you know how sick
yeah sickness is an enemy and you know
when job got sick and his wife said you
know curse God and die look what's
happened to you and he said you know
everybody in the world there's good and
bad that comes we're in a world where
the devil is brought sickness and it's
not just bad people are sinners it gets
sick everybody even believers get sick
and you know we're looking forward to
the day when there is no more painters
you know we do have these questions I
mean job had the same questions and
there's been many believing in God and
wondering why do do bad things happen to
good people you know that's where our
faith needs to just hold on to the
promises of God I think it's absolutely
appropriate for us to ask for healing a
matter of fact God tells us to do so but
then we also trust in him I think of the
experience of Elijah who was this great
prophet of God and he had a double
portion of the Holy Spirit
and yet we read about the last few
months or years of his life he had this
lingering illness that apparently
brought about his death and you wonder
why would this great man of God filled
with the spirit have to suffer that way
and some of these questions we just
don't know this side of heaven but we'll
see it clearly after Jesus comes yeah
and and the Lord does heal and he works
miracles
you know Evo it be if it's okay with you
we'll just have a quick prayer for is
this your grandson then James well let
me let's just pray together for him
right now father in heaven we just want
to join together and pray with Eva for
her grandson James who's struggling with
cancer right now and getting
chemotherapy and that she'll just give
the doctors and others wisdom as they
make decisions and most of all that
you'll just bring healing into this
situation Lord and and just please bless
and they grant your grace and I know
there's many others living that are
listening out there that are struggling
with similar challenges and we pray you
bring your healing into their lives as
well help them know that you are a
Living God and and please bless and do
miracles and and if you don't heal
I pray you give us grace to trust
nevertheless we thank you pray this in
Jesus name Amen
all right well thank you Eva and we'll
be remembering James I thinks well he's
Steve and he's listening from Washington
Steve well I wanted to hear me say swim
swim
the little mouse was right over the word
there I couldn't quite read it was know
where that is know where swim Washington
is how you doing Steve it is swim that's
correct yes I was hoping that you could
give me some clarity on the 144,000
issue all right well I'll share with you
and for our friends listening 144,000 is
a special group mentioned principally
twice in Revelation revelation 7 where
she double the number 7 you get 14 it's
in Revelation 7 in Revelation 14 it says
that they receive a seal of God they are
12,000 from the 12 tribes of Israel and
some have wondered are these literally
12,000 men
from the 12 tribes of Israel and one
verse it actually says for they are
virgins and heads it's a feminine term
and it gets very sore does that mean is
it 12,000 women from the 12 tribes what
does this mean
it's a spiritual term talking about a
special group say Jesus had 12 apostles
that went to the world during his first
coming to spread the gospel before the
second coming God is gonna pour out the
spirit in Pentecostal power again it's
called the latter rain of his spirit
he's gonna have 12 times 12 thousand
some will be literal Jews some may be
spiritual Jews but they're not
necessarily just from the tribes that
are mentioned he mentions those tribes
because the names of those tribes means
something the name Judah means I will
praise the Lord and so they're basically
like last day apostles that do a special
work the reason it says they are virgins
is because in Revelation talks about
women being a symbol for the Bride of
Christ and it means they are they have
pure truth and so I have a book I can
send you Steve that talks about the
hundred and forty-four thousand and I
don't know am I giving you enough
information you want a little more oh
well that that helps yeah but I think I
would like to I don't think the hundred
and forty-four thousand are the only
ones saved in the last days any more
than the Apostles were the only ones
that receive the Holy Spirit at
Pentecost in the Upper Room there wasn't
just the Twelve Apostles there was a
hundred and twenty and a great multitude
was converted from the Ministry of the
Twelve Apostles and the disciples before
Jesus comes there's going to be a
hundred and forty four thousand and
others that'll do a great ministry and a
great multitude is converted from their
ministry and you find that I believe in
revelation 7 that's right and they got
their father that know them in their
forehead it says you can also read about
them the first I think five verse the
revelation 14 also gives you certain
characteristics of 144,000 we'll have we
have a book on it we'll send you a free
book and if you don't want to wait to
get the book you can read
online but won't be happy to send it if
you halt the number the number to call
is 883 five six seven four seven you can
ask for the book who is 144,000 again
808 three five six seven four seven a
next caller is William listening right
here in Sacramento California William
welcome to the program hello hi William
you're on the air
yes my question is in light of chapter
Romans chapter Romans chapter nine 1
through 25
first Peter verses 1 and 2 and then
there are others for example like in the
Old Testament where God hardens
Pharaoh's heart so that he wouldn't
believe the well he's just hard his
heart so he wouldn't believe and also in
the book I don't have that one closely
but also in the book of Revelation where
he speaks of that those names are
written in the Lamb's Book of Life from
before the foundations of the world
right but it's totally Romans 9 1 to 25
how can the doctrine or the teaching of
free will that we choose God that he
doesn't choose us and even Jesus told
his disciples that I have chosen you you
haven't chosen me in there because he
said one of you will be a devil my guess
my question how can in light of those
passages and there are others that I
don't have right now right here how come
if we will be taught as a teaching of
Scripture well do you believe that
people have a choice in whether or not
they'll be saved I know which he had so
if if people do you think that it it
helps for us to go do mission work we
will well if God's already decided who
saved then why why try to work to
encourage people and persuade people to
accept Christ if they don't have a
choice well well the way I see that is
that if you have you know well I mean if
he's my brother's an example he's an
atheist he doesn't believe in God he has
nothing to do he doesn't even as far as
he's concerned God doesn't exist he's
nothing it doesn't bother him do you
pray for him
pray for your brother I pray for him but
now if God's already decided if he saved
her lost no matter how you pray then
your will and his will really has no
doesn't enter into it well yes but the
way I look at that is that God just gave
us the task of witnessing to people not
saving people we can't do that well when
when the Bible ends in Revelation and it
says the spirit and the bride say come
whosoever will let him take the water of
life freely doesn't that imply that we
get to choose okay
and then when when Joshua says choose
you this day whom for me in my house
we're going to serve the Lord doesn't
that seem to imply that we have a choice
yes what you just read there but you see
that contradict all chapter no no I just
wanted to set that up now in the minute
I've got left and I don't want to rush
it so you're asking a question about
predestination which is one of the big
subjects of Christian theologians I'm of
the opinion as his pastor Ross that
while God knows everything that's gonna
happen and he knows who's gonna be saved
because he knows the future doesn't mean
he's making it happen busy because in
order to love him we must choose you
can't force love you can't pre-program
people to love you and so God is we
believe made us were the free will to
choose to love him and that's why we're
to go and persuade people through
preaching of the gospel Paul is talking
about that you know God has elect that
he has called and some respond to that
invitation but many are called few
respond fewer chosen means you choose to
respond oh it's a big question you know
we do have a book that talks about that
can a saved man choose to be lost
William will send you a free copy listen
friends we want to thank you for calling
it if we didn't get your call tonight
please please give us another chance
God willing we'll be back in a week and
keep in mind the program can go on if
you just go to a
using fax dot o-r-g we've got just heaps
and oodles and gobs of Bible study
resources at the amazing facts website
videos you can watch audio free books
you can download studies that you can
print off for your classes that you
teach and that's simple amazing facts
dot o-r-g you appreciate the program
show us help us stay on the air and just
click donate god bless you we'll talk
again next time this has been a
pre-recorded broadcast of Bible answers
live a production of amazing facts
ministries if you would like to order
the materials mention on this broadcast
call 808 three five six seven four seven
from 8:00 a.m. to midnight Eastern
Standard Time that's 800 eight three
five six seven four seven if you've
missed an episode of Bible answers live
you can find it on our website amazing
facts dot o-r-g you'll also find our
online sale catalog of books tapes and
other materials as well as numerous free
resources on nearly every bible topic
putting the answers to your Bible
questions right at your fingertips if
you've been blessed by this program let
us know write to us at p o-- box nano
nine Roseville California nine five six
seven eight
be sure to tell others about the program
and join us again next time for more
Bible answers live with Pastor doug
batchelor hello friends we hope you've
enjoyed this episode of Bible answers
live amazing facts believes strongly in
the Great Commission given by Christ to
share the wonderful news of salvation to
the entire world for over forty-five
years
amazing facts has provided millions of
resources to people around the globe we
built churches in India held revivals in
Colombia and have given over 2 million
free Bible studies in the United States
alone the offer mention in the program
today will be sent to you absolutely
free to assist you in your study of the
Bible have you missed an episode
well visit our website at amazing facts
org for the latest programs and past
episodes these programs are brought to
you by caring individuals like you
they're known as our ministry partners
please consider joining our ministry
partners team your financial commitment
will help us keep programs like this on
the air so that the blessing you now
receive can be shared with others
friends the most amazing fact of all is
that God loves us he cares for us and he
has a plan for your life if you've
missed any of our programs would like to
become a financial partner please go to
our website at amazing facts dot o-r-g
if this program is blessed you
then tell afraind and thanks for joining
our efforts today in sharing the gospel
with the world is a curious thing I mean
just when things seemed under control
Wham you're hit with something new
your marriage is good suddenly it's on
the brink of divorce the job's great and
then it's gone and so's your life
savings you feel healthy any doctor
gives the bad news what's coming next
you could look to the stars but they
don't have the answers but this does the
prophecy Study Bible by amazing facts
this Bible special its 27 personal study
guides lead you on a life-changing
journey through God's Word to discover
real answers to life's questions from
health and relationships to family and
the future the hopes in here
get your amazing facts prophecy study
Bible today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
you